I'd like to welcome to the program today
Stephen Payson who received his
doctorate in economics from Columbia
University in 1991 he's been a
professional economist and adjunct
professor for about 32 years his latest
book which we'll be talking about today
is how economics professors can stop
failing us the discipline at a
crossroads this is a very very
interesting topic to me Steven as
someone who studied economics at both
the undergraduate and graduate level
regularly interviews economists
regularly debates economics with both
economists and non economists what would
you assess as the real crisis of
economic professorship that's going on
right now sure okay well I think first
of all before I you know say what the
crisis is I just want to say that
there's a lot of professors who are
doing very good work so I don't want it
to seem like you know I'm condemning all
professors anything like that certainly
but you know so having said that I think
there is a crisis it's pretty much a
crisis where the profession is too much
interested and too engaged and in a way
too trapped by its own games that it
plays internally for its career
promotion and its publications and the
kind of work that a lot of academic
economists do is really serving a sort
of game that doesn't produce much for
society give us an example of that in
other words what's something that
economist economics professors might put
time into that you believe doesn't serve
society is it the publishing of
theoretical economics articles or what
is it right I think a lot of it is a
focus too much on theory and too much
impressing people you know other
economists theoretical economists in the
same club so for example
studied for a couple decades
technological change and trying to
predict patterns of technological change
and it was a very interdisciplinary
approach which you know others some
other economists also take but the in my
view the literature on the effects of
technological change have been dominated
much more by theory where the theory
just builds up on on highly mathematical
constructs based on very very strong
assumptions and it kinds a it kind of it
kinds of produces more and more
publications without you know shedding
light on what's truly going on in
technological change so let me tell you
what one of the concerns I have with the
field of economics at least in most of
American colleges and universities and
you tell me number one if you agree or
disagree that this is an issue and
ideally whether you think it's connected
to what you just outlined which is I am
very concerned about the percentage of
the time that is spent teaching sort of
rational actor traditional economics
relative to the amount of time that's
spent really exploring the last twenty
years of behavioral economics and sort
of the way that a lot of these concepts
actually manifest in the real world do
you agree that that's a problem and is
that related to the problem you've
identified yes it is I agree it's a
problem and I and I agree that it's
related I think what's happened in
economics and part of it might be
tribute about to work by Gary Becker and
others has been this kind of option that
we don't have to truly understand human
behavior if we have an interesting model
that we can study and we could study the
mathematical properties of that model
and impress each other with what we've
discovered in our mathematical models so
it's sort of like understanding human
behavior is an option and there's a
substitute
which is you know more high-powered
theory where we just you know rediscover
essentially our assumptions about it and
it's amazing how this has affected so
many things because it also affects
economic policy because then you know if
you if you have an an economic problem
and we're trying to solve it and a
distinguished professor has a certain
theory based primarily on assumptions
but then can say I published a proof
that this is the best solution it's real
with the profession it doesn't have a
capability to really challenge that so
there isn't a strong enough leadership
to say wait a minute
how much of these assumptions are
grounded in reality you know the
assumptions are published in them in an
impressive journal then that sort of
like automatically elevates it to
acceptance do you believe that sort of
classical rational actor economics is
still a good basis for s students of
economics to first sort of understand if
humans were totally rational if we had
completely free markets if the laws of
supply and demand applied 100 percent in
the real world here's sort of how it
would work and then later be introduced
to for example the teachings of
behavioral economics or the limits of
capitalism or whatever else is that's
still the right order in your mind or
would you teach economics in a different
order I think it the the simple basis of
the ZURB neoclassical framework could
still be taught at the very first level
of explaining what supply and demand is
and maximizing utility and what
determines prices and everything else so
I think there's still that basic you
know element but then you know rather
than but then soon thereafter we've got
to introduce all the caveats and all the
other things that determine human
behavior before going you know
before piling it higher and deeper into
our own reality I think so maybe I don't
I don't know if you can speak to this
but I think that so my undergraduate
economics degree is from the University
of Massachusetts in Amherst
Massachusetts and I believe that that
was a unique Department insofar as you
know I had Marxist economist Richard
Wolff teaching my introduction to
macroeconomics a hundred level class as
a first year student and then very
quickly I was able to move into you know
the late Steve Resnick's class on
Marxian economics and other classes that
explored sort of the limits of
neoclassical economics was that
relatively unusual as far as economics
departments go I think so I think that
is very unusual you know I'm aware of
certain that you know departments like
that and some still exist you know but
that is unusual but we have to we have
to also be cautious because I think when
we're talking about I guess what we're
saying here is you're talking about
pluralism and economics and different
you know views other than the sort of
the neoclassical framework one thing
that that I talk about my book is we can
get too caught up in those scholarly
discussions and like you could say well
well this kind of helps round out
economics so that we understand things
better that's true but then you could
also you know we create a lot of other
distortions because you can have
scholars in the room talking about you
know what did Marx mean when he said
this that and the other thing and and
that that wouldn't be very productive
for economics they either so just the
general you know challenging the
simplicity of the new classical
framework is very good and principles
basic principles like labor exploitation
and those kind of things are good too
but if we get too much into the
and to scholarly discussions than a lot
of professors in those subfields tend to
have the same problem trying to impress
each other not necessarily with
mathematics but with you know their
quotations of what scholars had written
hundreds of years ago that kind of thing
do you think that so again anecdotally
when I was at the University of
Massachusetts economics was not part of
the business school it was it was part
of social sciences or of Humanities call
it what you want it has since been moved
into the business school and this is
something that we're actually seeing
around the country that increasingly
economics is being put under the
umbrella of learning about business is
that something that makes sense or
should we be concerned about that I I
would be concerned about that you know
you have to take these things into
context so if they're if it's a small
university they simply may not have an
economics department right and they may
teach a few economics classes and and it
would go under the business school but
like when I study economics at Columbia
was in the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences and we separate from the
business school and I think that's right
because they think economics you know
really should be seen as as a science as
a social science with applications to
business without also applications to
public policy applications international
trade you know that kind of thing how
concerned are you about sort of pop
economics I guess for lack of a better
term that's leading to just a lot of
people believing that they understand
economics in a way that they can
accurately assess what sort of public
and government policies would be
beneficial to the economy is that having
a real impact on government or is that
something that's just sort of going on
in media and is not impacting public
policy um I think it's always impacted
public policy and it's gotten worse in
some ways because what's happened and
maybe there might be some trends you
know to improve things recently but it's
hard to say but what's what's happened
is that
have become so complicated and so
dependent on very specific assumptions
that you can approach them with with
alternative sets of assumptions that
essentially rediscover those assumptions
and make very different conclusions so
you know if you wanna you know if you
want a model that says that if we reduce
the tax rate the economy will grow you
can produce a model like that if you
want a model that says the opposite you
could produce a model like that and and
you know the the devil is in the details
of the assumptions and the math and and
that kind of thing and even the way data
are process them and measured and
interpreted so what that what that has
meant for public policy is that there's
a lot of distrust and perhaps rightfully
so in the applications of economic
models in general and so that really
limits our ability to use economics
because if we don't trust economics then
we're just basing policies on God
instinct or what we really want to
believe if we don't like taxes we'll
think it faxes are bad if we want public
programs you think taxes is good to
finance our programs and so it's kind of
like economics has become so theoretical
that it's it's created a disbelief in
economics and so a lot of public leaders
simply don't believe economics we've
been speaking even pacing the book is
how economics professors can stop
failing us the discipline at a
crossroads very interesting topic and
and I find it particularly important
right now Steven thanks so much for
talking to us about this can I just I
just want to show this because the book
is on sale half-price oh sure ah and
it's a coupon at this website
absolutely fantastic ere leap org slash
P dot PDF for a radio and podcast
audience Steven thank you so much oh
thank you David thank you very much